[Music]
from James Cameron before he got
obsessed with blue people ponytail sags
comes a brilliantly simple plan to make
a lien even better fake it
aliens before you see the sequel to
whatever Prometheus was about revisit a
sequel that wasn't necessarily better
than the original but a damn sure was
bigger Yeller they are named bad and ten
times more booney er
you know this worked as they twisted a
horror film into a war movie but every
other action franchise disfigured good
sequel means loud noises
return to the grimy sweaty truck stop
bathroom that is the alien universe
nobody touched nothing and dust off your
undies to salute your dad's first crush
Ripley she's back in action after taking
out an alien single-handedly and still
no one listens to a thing she has to say
listen to me just one of those things
managed to wipe out my entire crew yeah
okay right but Ripley is not alone she's
riding with the colonial Space Marines
they may not be all that brave not that
in shape don't have the best discipline
and are more than a little bit creepy
sometimes there's some juicy colonists
daughters we have to rescue from their
virginity but that big gun is pretty
sweet
leadside characters who rise above being
disposable alien bait like Higgs the
grease painted soldier in all your
favorite movies Vasquez a master of
disguise cleverly pretending to be
latina yep same person and Bill Paxton
Hudson the Marine who literally can't
even beep ex it's never game over man
together they'll take on the nastiest
monster in the galaxy corporate middle
managers this installation has a
substantial dollar value attached to it
and also some Zeena Moore's perfect
killing machines who can only be
defeated by big-ass futuristic gods
assault rifles fire tiny little shotguns
and guns or extra slow robot punches
but man do they look scary it's like a
sex toy factory made out of scorpions so
strapped in with one of the greatest
sci-fi movies of all time that took all
the cool stuff
from the original like crawling through
ducts milky robots and the exact same
ending then added freakin mechs and a
Batmobile cuz even if you're making a
brutally dark sci-fi movie for adults
you still gotta sell a few toys still a
better story than Prometheus story the
talented Ellen Ripley hey Nick see you
Soph I'd the garbage pail kid mad about
you the packs man be up a plan up pop
see creepy oh my favorite twitch channel
yes Queen and the most badass moment in
sci-fi history get away from her you
[ __ ] whoa aliens yep that actually sums
it up pretty good
Ripley I got one question for you what
are those game over man game over power
don't come from a badger gun power comes
from lying he may have been your father
boy but he wasn't your daddy Norman
Reedus is my husband he just doesn't
know it yet
waffles are just pancakes with